rappelez-vous la semaine dernière Alex a
eu un geste déplacé envers Valérie
Benaim pour recontextualiser la scène
mercredi dernier en début d'émission les
chroniqueurs ont dansé en duo parmi ces
duos Valérie Alex alors qu'il réalisait
une simple danse voilà Alex
Alex voilà eu un geste déplacé envers
Valérie il n'est pas revenu dans
l'émission depuis ça depuis ça et on a
l'IM il a dit qu'il l'impression d'être
devenu l'ennemi public numéro 1 il va
nous en parler dans un instant euh juste
avant vous vous avez vu ce ça a fait un
énorme buz autour de d'Alex cette
histoire c'est vrai on a vu he
aujourd'hui tout le monde parlait que de
ça Gill par exemple vous comment vous
avez vécu le le truc alors en direct
nous on avait dansé avec geréraldine je
n'ai pas vu ce qui s'est passé après
j'ai été extrêmement choqué j'ai échangé
avec Alex le lendemain matin je lui ai
dit que j'étais choqué qu'il fallait
faire des excuses plates total et absolu
à Valérie que le geste n'était pas
tolérable moi je pense qu'effectivement
c'est un geste qui doit être entre
guillemets sanctionné c'est-à-dire
éditorialement ou par sa non présence
dans l'émission voilà on peut pas
laisser passer ça est parvenu depuis
voilà vous avez raison moi je trouve que
vous avez maîtrisé l'antenne et tout de
suite et après en y revenant donc ça il
y a pas de problème maîtrise de
l'antenne mais le geste le geste pour
moi est parfaitement déplacé voilà peux
dire quelque chose toi tu Val tu parler
après c'est toi qui Vaas avoir la parole
c'est normal que c'est toi qui va te qui
va parler de ça on on a on a tout vu on
a dansé moi je l'ai vu en direct et
quand je l'ai vu en direct je dis wouh
là ça va être la merde parce que il
essaie de la porter je sais pas ce qu'il
veut faire en tout cas c'est très
maladroit et le geste est très maladroit
c'est dans l'enflamade il vient
d'arriver dans l'émission il veut faire
TPMP il veut il veut s'imposer il veut
donner il veut donner le change et c'est
une véritable connerie on l'a tous dit
ici vous vous lui avez dit pendant la
pub il s'est excusé en direct vous avez
tenu l'antenne comme il fallait derrière
bah on a vu sur Twitter tout ce qui
s'était passé et c'est là que je me suis
voilà ça va être la merde la merde elle
est là parce qu'en voulant jouer en vou
en voulant faire le marrant on voulant
faire le guignol il a fait un truc qui
est très déplacé et Valérie l'a excusé s
excusé tu en as parlé avec lui tu l' tu
l'as pour l'instant sorti l'antenne pour
moi c'est c'est c'est c'est une vraie
connerie pour moi mais après ça mérite
tout ça toi qui a plus pr Val ouais de
la même manière effectivement je n'ai
pas vu le Gest donc je l'ai vu après
effectivement à l'image et effectivement
à l'image c'est très choquant c'est très
gênant c'est une vraie c'est une vraie
agression c'est un vrai attouchement
sans
consentement donc j'ai été très choquée
j'ai été très choquée au départ par les
excuses de Alex G qui pour moi a dit ce
qu' avait de pire il a dit non mais de
toute façon moi en gros je ne mange pas
de ce painl en gros mais ça c'est
s'excusé d'avoir dit ça après ouais mais
en fait ça fait beaucoup d'excuses en
fait on s'excuse de s'excuser en gros je
suis homosexuel donc en fait ça n'est
pas bah si en fait c'est pas parce qu'on
est homosexuel qu'on a le droit de
toucher le cul d'une femme ou les seins
d'une femme ou les parties de n'importe
qui donc je trouve qu'il fait aussi
beaucoup de mal à Ste d'homophobie
ambiante qui règne partout aujourd'hui
en France donc voilà donc ça a pas été
une bonne défense de sa part voilà donc
il s'est excusé je crois beaucoup
platement sans aue ambig et il veut
voilà par ça été très très dur pour
luiès Valé parler parce VI Val parlera
dans un instant mais c'est vrai que
Alex voilà il VI ilit des moment aussi
très compliqués depuis
jacqu moi je vais pas revenir sur le
geste alors j'étais pas là ce soir là
j'étais pas dans l'émission je l'ai vu
dans la soirée je me suis dit voilà
c'était c'est terrible et je me suis
pris de sympathie pour Alex depuis qu'il
est arrivé on a nous aussioup beaucoup
changé on a plein de choses en commun on
a parlé de son passé de footballeur et
j'ai appris qu'il était gardien de but
quand il était jeune c'est pas du tout
des je je je je dis juste que j'ai eu
non non mais je dis juste que parce que
je vois tout de suite des regards et je
me dis où il va mais je je j'ai de la
sympathie pour lui je trouve que tout ce
qui va se passer enfin voilà c'est c'est
je je je suis triste de de de de la
façon dont ça se passe maintenant je me
prononce pas du tout sur le geste parce
que il est pas acceptable il est
inadmissible on s'est parlé il m'a
appelé le lendemain ou le sur lendemain
euh parce que il avait je pense envie
d'échanger et puis que bien sûr tous les
jours dans cette émission où très
régulièrement il peut y avoir des
clashes et par moment on peut un peu mal
exprimer les choses je parle de la
parole mais là il s'agit d'un geste et
le geste il est pas acceptable on doit
pas voir ça c'est fini 2023 voilà et lui
le sait et moi je sais que ça n'est pas
lui et donc ça me fait beaucoup de peine
et j'espère que voilà pour ça qu'on qu'
viennent ce soir parce que il faut
mettre voilà les choses au clair Valérie
c'est toi la principale euh euh ben
écoute je vais dire ce que je pense je
passe mon temps ici à dire que bah
jeunes filles aux jeunes femmes que il
faut rien laisser passer que tous les
les gestes inappropriés bah il faut
absolument immédiatement le dire donc je
vais pas me dédire effectivement j'ai
détesté le geste d'Alex voilà je n'ai
pas j'ai pas aimé c'est un geste
totalement inapproprié et en même temps
j'ai détesté ma réaction parce que sur
le moment bah j'ai pas su réagir ah
ouais j'ai pas su réagir et donc ça fait
penser aux autres femmes qui savent pas
forcément toujours réagir on est dans un
contexte particulier il y a un plateau
de télé il y a des gens qui rient je ne
sais pas si moi j'ai bien vécu ce que
j'ai vécu et c'est pour ça que je
voulais te remercier Cyril parce que tu
as validé ce que moi j'avais vécu
c'est-à-dire que comme tu l'as vu aussi
tu as immédiatement pardon je te tutoie
mais vous avez immédiatement dit vous
avez immédiatement dit stop ça ne se
fait pas et par cette chose- là vous
avez validé ce que je ressentais à ce
moment-là que toi tu'en a même pas rendu
compte c'estàd si si je m'en suis tout à
fait rendu compte non non je m'en suis
tout à fait rendu compte mais bah on moi
mon mécanisme de défense c'est de c'est
de rire donc je mets à distance en riant
immédiatement j'ai mis à distance en
riant immédiatement et par le fait de
dire vous Cyril stop là tu tu es
complètement taré qu'est-ce que tu fais
ça a validé mon ressenti et le fait de
le valider je voudrais dire d'ailleurs à
tous les gens la réaction de Cyrille
elle est elle est parfaite et quand vous
voyez quelque chose qui vous semble
inapproprié osez le dire parce que ça
peut aider la personne qui le vit à ce
moment-là parce que on est à même nous
de se dire mais est-ce que j'en fais des
caisses est-ce que c'est trop est-ce que
c'est moi qui surréagis est-ce que voilà
donc euh vraiment merci alors on s le
soir après on va le dire on s'en a pas
on' parlé après et et évidemment j'en ai
parlé avec Alex qui immédiatement lui
sur le coup ne s'en est pas rendu compte
et au fur et à mesure s'en est rendu
compte et on en a on a échangé beaucoup
ce qui est important c'est dans quel
comment Alex l'a fait est-ce qu'il y
avait une intention de malveillante il y
avait aucune intention malveillante de
sa part j'en suis absolument persuadé
depuis ça a été un voilà on en a
beaucoup parlé il était dévasté il m'a
offert un bouquet de fleurs je vais pas
révéler la teneur de nos échanges mais
on a eu des échanges voilà de voilà en
toute transparence et sur nos nos vécus
respectifs excuse acceptter voilà à
faire clause je voudrais juste ajouter
une petite chose ce qui est intéressant
c'est que dès la fin de l'émission j'ai
vu la charge inversée c'est-à-dire que
j'étais enfin évidemment Alex a vécu
plein de choses mais de mon côté j'ai
été sommé par les réseaux sociaux par
tout le monde de de réagir de commenter
et où j'en faisais trop où j'en faisais
pas assez alors d'un côté j'en faisais
pas assez parce que j'avais ri et faut
pas rire mais on se débrouille on fait
comme on peut hein pardon et de l'autre
côté j'en faisais trop parce que bon ça
va c'est juste une main au cul ben en
fait on fait comme on peut et on fait
comme on veut je dis à toutes FEM fait
comme on peut et on fait comme on veut
bra voilà et et et je voudrais dire bah
parce que moi voilà c'est passé c'est
voilà et et vraiment encore une fois
excuse accepté Alex on passe à autre
chose mais je pense à des femmes qui
ontag votre compagnon vous en a parlé
bien sûr V compagnon mon fils mon père
euh oui c'est pas ma mèrei euh ça
restera entre nous ils étaient pas un
moment qui est pas agréable pour eux
parce qu' ils savaient que c'était pas
un moment agréable pour moi
mais juste je vrais terminer sur ça
juste dire aux jeunes femmes qui qui qui
nous regardent qui et qui ont vécu des
choses qui n'ont rien à voir qui sont à
des degrés voilà parce qu'il y a des
hiérarchies aussi dans ce qu'on subit pu
il y a des gens qui le font exprès et
d'autres qui le font pas exprès voilà
mais en l'occurrence voilà vous faites
comme vous voulez vous faites comme vous
pouvez et personne n'a de mots à dire
sur ce que vous dites ou ce que vous
faites voilà alex est avec nous Alex
merci Alex qui alors c'est vrai qu'on a
pas de Magneto donc merci Alex d'être là
merci je sais que c'est c'est pas
évident merci mon merci merci
assie-toitoi ass-toi mon chéri voilà
donc c'est vrai
que voilà Valérie et vous et toi vous
êtes beaucoup parlé j'ai vu Alex que
depuis depuis ce qui s'est passé depuis
le retour sur la séquence est-ce que dès
dès le début de la séquence tu t'es dit
j'ai merdi en fait sur le moment
si tu veux je peux trouver tous les
excuses de la terre c'està dire on
faisait une danse de couple je suomo je
voulais faire un mouvement dans sa clar
mais en fait la vérité c'est que toutes
les excuses de la terre sont bidon tu
voilà c'est inadmissible c'est pas
normal j'aurais jamais dû faire ça je
sais pas ce qui m'a pris je n'ai même
jamais fait ce Gest là dans ma vie à
personne ever ça te ressemble pas du
tout àex je nai jamais fait ça même dans
ma vie même à mes mecs j'ai jamais fait
ça ça m'est jamais arrivé donc je voilà
je sais pas c'est un pétage de câble
comme d'ailleurs sur le moment voilà
donc je après tu tu comprends l'ampleur
du truc parce que c'est le monde dans
lequel on vit je suis rentré chez moi
ben j'ai pas dormi he j'ai pas dormi
pant 3 jours d'ailleurs donc c'est aussi
simple que ça ça été quoi pendant 3
jours bah mais c'est comme ça et c'est
mérité quelque part si tuux c'est juste
que la dimension est tellement immense
entre les menaces de mort les machin
tout mais mais je suis pas la victime je
suis le bourreau donc je vais pas te
dire que c'est compliqué dans dans
l'absolu évidemment que c'est compliqué
c'est qu' la famille pour les proches
mais c'est tout aussi compliqué pour
Valérie d'avoir encore les images qui
sont partout balancées dans tous les
sens parce que les réseaux c'est comme
ça il y a des mêmes il y a des machins
parmi les images moi ce ça part partout
je te remercie beaucoup et merci déjà de
de me faire venir mais voilà après la
réité c'est que j'ai 50 p j'apprends
encore les trucs aujourd'hui et et c'est
bien d'encore apprendre mais si j'avais
pu éviter d'apprendre comme ça aurait
été très bien et je me suis déjà excusé
bon mais qu'est-ce que dis tu dis depuis
depuis tu vis un cauchemar par Al ça
alors ça faut aussi rétablir l'histoire
c'est que Y a tuas un journaliste hier
soir de pur média pour pas citer qui
m'appelle en me disant tu es virer tes
PMP moi je sais très bien ce que nous on
s'est dit et avec toi avec le nel qui
était pas du tout le cas éit dire
attends j'ai besoin de respirer 2
secondes parce que ce que je vis est
très complexe pour Valérie aussi
d'ailleurs et je lu dis non pas du tout
Valérie voilà on voulait pas et je dis
non non pas du tout juste laissez-moi je
me repose c'est très compliqué c'est
très compliqué pour euh pour moi pour ma
maman tu vois qui est une mère juive
dans tous les sens du terme qui a vécu
un moment un peu complexe voilà avec
tout ça qui connait pas trop les résex
sociaux mais quielle été traîné jeudi
qui a été voir qui a vu les menaces de
mort les machins et tout qui a fait un
malaise ou tu as des malaes de mort ta
maman a fait un malaise oui oui ben j'ai
tout euu en fait mais c'est encore une
fois c'est c'est pas l'objectif on s'en
fout de raconter ça c'est ma vie perso
voilà c'est juste dire que je voilà je
veux mettre ça derrière moi j'ai appris
ma leçon il y a pas de problème je suis
pas débile je je comprends bien tout ce
que j'ai fait voilà j'apprends encore
enc une fois et ça ne se reproduira plus
jamais ça t'était déjà repruit jamais
avant dans ma vie ça ne se reproduira
plus jamais après je comprends tous les
messages que j'ai reçu aussi de gens qui
étaient qui étaient choqués avec qui
j'ai discuté parce que j'essayie de
répondre à tout le monde sur les réseaux
tu te dis quoi à ce moment-là tu te dis
je vais faire un mot je vais faire un
truc qu'est-ce que tu dis mais en fait
le problème c'est que sur le moment on
s'est excusé même si geréraldy na pas
mes excuses mais parce que c'était
peut-être maladroit c'est aussi toi qui
a dit que j'étais homo he plus que moi
qui dit tout de suite mais mais la la la
réalité tu as dit oui que ça risque rien
mais en fait si ça risque quoi qu'il
arrive mais la réité c'est que je me
suis excé sur le moment 10 minutes après
le lendemain le soir même et le
lendemain va aller ré dire que l'ASS
était clos et je m'étais dit je je vais
arrêter de communiquer ça sert à rien
parce que en fait si ça vient de moi
quoi que je dise c'est le délire donc
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça je te remercie
que tu as dit je vais prendre les choses
en main moi et et on va en parler ici
mais mais voilà
c'est voilà quoi c'est c'est le moment
le plus dur que ah bah oui oui ça c'est
sûr que c'est le moment le plus dur que
j'ai jamais vécu ma carrière parce que
dans la vie perso tu as toujours des
moments compliqués on va pas qu'est-ce
que tu auras dire à Alex que c'est ça on
s'est dit déj beaucoup parl chose encore
une fois je je je redis c'est-à-dire que
euh Alex n'avait aucune intention et en
de de de de de de me faire du mal de de
de que je reçois que que je ressente un
sentiment d'humiliation comme ça ça pu
me traverser et cetera à ce moment-là ou
même après euh et je et je et je dis je
dis encore une fois il y a toute une
palette dans ce qu'on appelle les
agressions sexuelles il y a toute une
palette et mais qu'est-ce que tu
qu'est-ce que vousêes dit en tu l'
engueulé tu lu dit quoi la
vérité quoi disnous les choses
AB tu dit quoi c'est inapproprié c'est
voilà mais j'avais j'ava j'avais en face
de moi un homme qui était dans la
contrition totale ouais parce que encore
une fois c'est pas pareil c'est pas je
suis pas je ne suis pas une jeune femme
qui était dans le métro avec un type qui
avait une intention sexuelle et qui
s'est frotté à elle dans un but sexuel
ou qui lui a mis une main aux fesses
dans un but sexuel j'avais un garçon qui
a voulu faire une vanne qui a dérapé
qui s'en est immédiatement excusé après
j'ai pas vécu le moment de façon
formidable il l'a pas vécu non plus
comment tu as vécu le déferlement sur
Alex est-ce que tu dis toi honnêtement
au départ j'ai pas du tout géré ce ce
truc je me disais c'est son problème
c'est pas le mien après tout pourquoi ça
serait mon problème
ouais bien sûr et puis après j'ai de
l'empathie et je voyais le désar parce
que je te connais Valérie je sais que un
moment tu m'as appelé tu m'as dit c'est
vrai que voilà tu étais tu étais tu
étais pas bien aussi alors que c'était
toi qui avais qui qui a é parce que
voilà VO oui parce que parce que VO
parce que la charge encore une fois
inversée c'està-dire que j'ai pu lire
oui mais elle dansait col les ser enfin
c'està-dire je pense à tout ce queon
peut dire aussi à des femmes bon
euh euh oui au début je me suis dit
c'est son problème c'est sa patate
chaude il se débrouille avec il avait
cap parce que on passe dans un moment un
peu de colère et puis après on a discuté
et moi j'ai de l'empathie et encore une
fois je le redis Alex n'était pas animé
de d'intention malveillante il voulait
pas m'humilier il voulait pas faire mal
il voulait s'amuser il s'est planté il
s'est trompé l'affaire est close tout va
bien il a toute mon amitié encore voilà
c'estis je sais qu'il est qu'il est pas
bien on passe à autre
chose mon Alex c'est vrai que G aussi
t'adore c'est vrai qu' on était tous mal
après cette histoire on te le dit parce
que tu as un garçon qu'on adore vraiment
voilà on a on étit voilà c'est vrai
voulais lui poser une question oui Alex
est-ce que vous avez tout de suite
mesuré que ce geste allit vous suivre
très longtemps est-ce que vous vous êtes
dit non seulement j'ai fait une
monstrueuse erreur mais je vais être
marqué par ça d'orén avant non non non
mais j'ai compris la sur le moment
évidemment tu dis ou là là c'est c'est
c'est typique le genre de truc qui peut
aujourd'hui vraiment dégénérer et à JRE
heureusement heureusement que c'est la
fin des mains au cul quoi qu'il arrive
de toute façon c'est quand même une
bonne chose dans l'histoire de
l'humanité donc je me suis ou là là oui
c'est vrai que ça peut dé générer je
pensais pas que ça irait à ce niveau-là
et de cette puissance là mais après
c'est aussi une caisse de résonance ici
énorme tu vois donc on est sur
l'émission la plus vue du PAF atteindre
c'est aussi quelque part atteindre cyil
atteindre l'émission si quand tu vois le
nombre de de vues de n'importe quel
article fait sur ce Tru c'est sidérant
c'est plus que ce que j'ai eu quand
j'été nommé entraîneur enfin animateur
de ce que tu veux des grosses émissions
que j'ai pu faire dans mon histoire avec
des 7 millions de spectateurs ça n'a
rien à voir ça prend des proportion
hallucinante donc évidemment je d pas je
démarre ici je suis comme vous je sais
que vous avez tous eu à un moment donné
ou un autre de toute façon tous des
problèmes avec les réseaux sociaux et
oui donc je découvre l'empur de truc
donc je pensais pas que c'était à ce
point-là pour répondre à ta question je
savais très TR bien que j'ava fait une
connerie mais voilà à ce point-là non
gine il y a plein de gens qui sur
Twitter qui disent ça va il a il a il a
tué personne il a violer personne
qu'est-ce que tu dis bien sûr de la même
manière qu' on en a beaucoup parlé
effectivement je suis absolument
d'accord avec ce qui se dit et et de la
même manière qu'il y a une hiérarchie
c'est pas pareil un attouchement une
agression voilà mais le problème
aujourd'hui aussi et on en a parlé c'est
que bah une mauvaise blague de texte on
le dégage une main aux fesses on dégage
et ben un viol on dégage donc en fait il
y a il y a il y a la même sanction pour
tout le monde donc j'incite quand même
les gens à aller porter plainte pas dans
ce cas-là bien évidemment mais quand
c'est vraiment une agression sexuelle
dans le métro et qu'on a peur et et
c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de il y a pas
de de hiérarchie en fait aujourd'hui
dans al tu as véc comment tu as vécu
cette semaine
non mais la semaine a été extrêmement
complexe probablement je dis la pire de
ma vie ever la pire de ta vie oui
franchement oui oui ça a été très très
dur mais mais c'était je savais aussi à
quel point c'était dur pour Valérie de
voir des mêmes partout et de me dire
mais comme comment je peux endiguer le
truc qu'est-ce que je peux faire après
tout le mond disait mais non mais ne dis
rien parce que je dis quelque chose tu
remets une P dans la machine mais même
aujourd'hui on va se le dire tu vois je
non non mais aujourd'hui tu
voilà on s dit cet après-midi avec
Valérie je mais j'avais pas envie que ça
remette dans la machine je dis mais
c'est jeux plus de ça quoi j'en peux
plus en fait voilà donc je suis fatigué
mais c'est rien ça va passé tu as pas
réussi à dormir pendant une semaine non
non c'est compliqué on dit quoi tes
proches par je c'est surtout ma mère qui
m'inquiète voilà c'est mère je vraiment
dans tous les sens du terme à maman Mo
MAM d' à Casablanca aussi comme comme
toi j'embrasse à maman et j'en joins
tout le monde et encore une fois à avoir
un peu de de pondération et à savoir
qu'il y a des êtres humains lui et moi
et que par
ailleurs raison le problème c'estour
c'est toi ta famille moi ma famille
c'est ça le problème on se rend pas
compte tu vois il y a il y a une
hiérarchie dans les choses encore une
fois encore une fois Alex n'est pas un
frotteur dans le métro dans le métro
n'est pas un violeur enfin il y a des
hiérarchies dans les chos voilà et et
donc il a des degré aussi dans le dans
les réactions qu'on doit qu'on doit
avoir et malheureusement il paye aussi
enfin d'une certaine manière aussi tu
payes aussi pour l'époque c'est-à-dire
que avec ce geste cert déplacé tu l'as
dit 200 fois et il y a aucune ambigué et
passons à autre chose si on normalise ce
geste là à au niveau de tes PMP qui
regardé par des jeunes alors qu'on parle
de harcèlement on parle de violence et
tout ça et que il y a une gamine qui
elle par ailleurs subit par exemple des
des mains au fesse répéter dans son
école et surtout d'aille au niveau des
réactions si tu veux au niveau des
réactions beaucoup de gensus 30 m'ont
dit oh là là mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce délire c'est un et tout et c'est
surtout les
jeunes des jeunes de 20 ans 25 ans qui
m'écrivent et à qui voilà je je discute
avec parce que j'essaie de répondre à
tout le monde voilà mais mais
effectivement c'est surtout c'est c'est
un problème générationnel tu as eu
beaucoup de coup de fil bah des coups de
fil oui pas mal des gens qui disaient
quoi comment ça va ou pour ououi c'est
ça non surtout des gens qui essayent de
se renseigner de savoir comment tu vas
et comment ça se passe parce que je
t'avoue que j'étais vraiment débordé par
le truc ouais c'est ça voilà tu as jou
au ce weekend non j'ai j'ai rien fait ce
weekendien fait j'ai essayé de partir
même et puis ça ça a rien arrangé donc
voilà ouais donc là tu avais envie là tu
as envie de de de couper tu avais envie
de couper complètement oui oui
d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai dit à ce
journaliste qui du coup a dit il arrête
la télé il veut partir au Guatemala il
vait des vaches non voilà c'est juste
que j'ai besoin tranquillement de me
remettre de ça que se remette et voilà
ouais ça a été un ouais ça a été un
moment très
compliqué tu as regardé les réseaux tu
regardes encore ou là tuas arrêté non
ben moi j'essaie de regarder parce que
j'essaie de répondre ouais mais non
voilà les trucs d'une ex violence voilà
je réponds pas bien sûr les menaces de
mort les condamnations les machin tout
ce que tu veux je réponds pas mais après
les gens qui sont qui sont choqués à qui
je peux discuter j'essaie de discuter
avec eux et voilà il arrêté on le sait
voilà je ferai plus jamais ça ever ou et
puis encore une fois je l'avais jamais
fait avant c'est ça le plus fou c'est
que de ma vie j'ai jamais mis la main au
C à personne mais ever voilà c'est c'est
on s'est parlé le lendemain ou le sur
lendemain je sais plus tu m'as tu m'as
appelé et on a partagé nos nos
impressions de de début de chroniqueur
parce que c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
fausse d'une certaine façon
euh ça peut aller très vite ça peut
déraper très vite et il y a une mise en
abîme qui est très forte on a tu as
raison
une on parle on est on on taille
beaucoup les les gens et on est
impitoyable avec avec des politiques
avec les juges et cetera et on essaie de
le faire le plus justement possible donc
on ne peut pas ne pas le faire pour nous
c'est ça exactement et donc ça on a on a
ce devoir là absolument aux jeunes et en
plus nous globalement on est plutôt
d'une génération où on aurait tendance à
dire bon c'est pas trop grave sauf qu'on
on ne doit plus dire ça on sait qu'on ne
peut plus dire ça et donc on sait et et
Alex savait quand on c'est pas qu'on ne
peut plus c'est qu'on ne doit plus non
mais on bien sûr c'est ce que je dis
quand je disais tout à l'heure non mais
tu sais j'ai une fille qui qui a 25 ans
je parle avec elle et elle me dit papa
c'est pas 2023 en fait donc arrête avec
ça c'est pas 2023 donc moi je sens bien
je je le sens et quand j'ai eu alex je
vis juste terminer là-dessus je sais que
ça n'est pas toi et je voudrais que
voilà je voulais juste le dire par
amitié mais c'est déconnecté évidemment
de ce geste de tout ce qu'on dit qui
doit avoir valeur d'exemple à l'égard
des jeunes et à l'égard de tout le monde
c'est évident Alex tu as envie de quoi
aujourd'hui
là rien de me dire que c'est le point
final de cette histoire c'est fini et
que autre sujet quoi exactement voilà
plus on s'est éclaté avec toi je te dis
la vérité on adore quter avec nous tout
le monde t'adore dans l'équipe vraiment
tu as été vraiment accueilli par tout le
monde parce que tu es un garçon avec qui
on adore être donc c'est vrai que voilà
même nous ça nous pé Valérie voulait
terminer oui non je je voulais juste
dire à tous ceux qui se disaient outrer
tout en partageant en même temps la
capture d'écran avec le gros plan avec
la photo cette forme d'hypocrisie en
disant on est outré mais on fait quand
même circuler la photo voilà bah si vous
êtes vraiment outré vous enlevez la
photo des réseaux et moi moi je voudrais
juste dire à ceux aussi qui sont tombés
sur Valérie pour lui dire oui c'est quoi
ta réaction tu rigoles et cetera Valérie
c'est une grande fille Valérie elle est
extrêmement intelligente elle sait
exactement où elle va et ce qu'elle doit
faire donc elle a elle a de conseil à
recevoir de personne donc les donneurs
de leçon euh qui sont venus euh sur
Valérie et qui ont commencé à insulter
Valérie parce qu'elle avait pas eu pour
eux la bonne réactionz occupez-vous de
vous et laisser Valérie gérer sa vie et
gérer sa carrière elle le fait très bien
depuis des années et des années donc ça
moi euh les donneurs de leçon une fois
de plus euh occupez-vous de votre cul
voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais vous
dire et je pense que c'est c'était le
moment de le dire euh voilà ma Valérie
ça va toi ma chérie ouis ça va très bien
non mais ça va c'est voilà Alex vraiment
je te dis Valérie même elle était pas
bien parce que elle t'aime énormément et
que au départ elle était très énervée
après toi je te le dis comme tout le
monde c'est nor et après bah elle s'est
dit mine de rien c'est pas Alex c'était
voilà et elle a elle a voilà même elle
elle était très triste de voilà de de de
ce qui s'était passé entre vous voilà en
tout cas merci d'être venu ce soir merci
à tous à
demain